What if Russia Wins the war in Ukraine?
If Russia is able to defeat Ukraine
even after a lot of support of western powers,
it could have significant
implications for both regional and global politics.
Russia may become more assertive as a great power
and potentially
pose a threat to neighbouring countries in the region
like Finland and Sweden.
Russian population is decreasing
and the decreasing population
is threat to any nation power.
Russia winning Ukraine will add a population
of 40 million to Russian population
and solve the demographic problems.
Additionally,
Russia and Ukraine together
make up about 30% of total week export of the world.
After the Ukraine annexation,
Russia will control food supply
and will be able to dictate it.
Russian victory will empower China
and invasion of Taiwan will become imminent.
But right now this does not seems to be happening.
What do you think will happen if Russia wins the war?